so wurden damals die größten Youtuber
von Youtube Netzwerken abgezockt ich
erzähle euch meine krasseste Story wobei
ich mich natürlich nicht zu den größten
Youtubern von damals zähle 2011 bis 2015
war so die Hochzeit der
youtube-netzwerke alle großen Youtuber
von damals waren in irgendeinem Netzwerk
könnt ihr euch wie ein Musikmanagement
vorstellen nur ein bisschen anders und
irgendwann sind dann auch immer mehr
Unternehmen darauf aufmerksam geworden
dass man mit diesen Youtubern halt
unfassbar viel Geld verdienen kann ein
wirklich sehr großes deutsches
Unternehmen hat mich dann gebucht eine
riesen Kooperation mehrere Videos
mehrere Instagram Postings und ich hatte
zu der Zeit eigentlich immer mehr als
200.000 Aufrufe auf meine Youtube Videos
wie ich später erfahren habe haben die
für das ganze 42000 € bezahlt und jetzt
passt auf 50% ging erstmal an die sales
Abteilung meines damaligen Netzwerks
mediakraft Hälfte schon mal weg und der
Rest ging dann zu mir wobei ich davon
noch mal 30 % Abdrücken musste sprich
obwohl ich die ganze Arbeit hatte sind
am Ende nur 14000 von den 25000 bei mir
angekommen und da gab es noch viel
extremere Beispiele trotzdem Arsch viel
Geld keine Frage also das